i'm so curious when you got cast i'm
sure you met with jeb
how much did he tell you about your
character and like the ultimate arc of
the series because the thing about
vikings is like anyone can sort of be
killed at any time
um
so when we first when we first met for
this show they were still using
pseudonyms uh for the characters so we
didn't know necessarily who the
historical characters we were but if you
linked up a few of the things that you
could pick out the scripts you could you
could work it out so i've worked out who
who i was playing so i had a pretty good
idea of the
the broad historical strokes and so at
the screen test i sat down with jeff and
i went right so there's this guy right
he went yes this guy right he does this
this and this and he goes yeah he does
this doesn't this i said well i get to
do that yeah i get to do that
and he says do you wanna know what else
i said yeah what else he says well i'm
gonna do this between that bit i'm gonna
do this between that bit i'm gonna do
this between that bit i was like
can i have the job
i mean this is this is a guy who wrote
die hard in the fugitive this is a guy
who writes
beautiful thrillers that keep you
guessing with great characterizations
and he's written this historical epic
which i love about vikings which i
[ __ ] love and playing the characters
basically alan rickman from die hard i
mean
that that's it like i'm sold like do you
want to do it yeah of course you want to
do it first of all that's great i love
that um what do you think soon-to-be
fans of the show would be surprised to
learn about the actual behind the scenes
of the making of the show
i mean most uh most of the first season
the show was done during the strict
discovery lockdowns uh that that would
be amazing to see i mean we were one of
the very first shows to go back up and
running uh which it was
hugely down to the deep pockets of mgm
and netflix for having the confidence in
us to get us up and going because they
knew they had a they had a hit on their
hands um what were they what would he be
surprised by i i mean
the fact that we're trying to tell the
story of all of northwestern europe but
in eight hours yeah it's it's not a
small it's not not an unambitious
project
listen when i'm watching the show i
couldn't believe the first four episodes
how fast-moving they were and that effin
london bridge sequence which is like a
movie scale on the show um what was your
reaction reading these scripts and like
and then seeing that london sequence
i i'm i was just awed by the
arrogance of chad stewart to put a
finale action sequence at the midway
point of a tv show um and then i was
like okay so what are you gonna do in
episode eight um and then i read that
and i was like ah [ __ ] i'm still in
london
um no i think i think that's the thing
with jeb is that even when it comes down
to structuring how a series develops and
evolves by putting a set piece like that
episode four
like that's
that's unconventional and brilliant and
when jeb leans into that that's that's
where he comes into his own he's
absolutely brilliant uh the character
you play has a lot going on in the
subtext uh how much fun is it playing
that uh because you can see behind the
eyes he is thinking about ten different
things
how much should the show have you seen
so far
seen the first six episodes
okay so you have no idea
[Laughter]
got it so
the finale is something
the trajectory that godwin has
planned out
is something that will not be resolved
by the end of this series and it will
not be resolved by the end of the next
series his his long game is
is a really impressive one well the
other thing about this is like normally
i talk to actors and i you know i say
talk about season one and i'm like oh i
really hope you get to do season two but
you guys have already filmed season two
which is awesome um and i by the way
with everyone i've been interviewing
with the facial hair i'm like oh season
three seems pretty pretty likely with
everyone the way everyone's dressed i
have a lot of hair tied up back here
that's all i can say but no please every
actor who has facial hair and i'm like
oh it's season three is going to get
announced at some point um but what can
you tease about season two
um
i mean it's a historical story you can
go through some history books and find
out um i think i think for godwin what
is particularly interesting
is
if season one you've seen him
starting to solidify his position
and nothing other than that in season
two you watch him make his first move
and it's literally his first pawn in the
in the chess game
is is played in season two and
everything in season one is simply
laying out the board
one of the things about the show is
because it's an ensemble cast you know
i'm sure you have many days you don't
have to go to set what is it actually
like because of covid were you sort of
like locked down in the hotel where like
you couldn't do much what was it like in
between when you when you not have to be
on set
um
knowing that i was going to be locked
down and all that stuff um
my partner and i who was pregnant at the
time took our dog out we didn't live in
dublin we moved out into countryside we
lived in a big ol botanical garden that
was shot to the public
um so we had 14 acres of land to
to spend our days off together walking
our dog enjoying the sunshine and it was
a glorious summer um in in ireland that
year um yeah we
we
like godwin foresaw many of the problems
that lay ahead
and planned accordingly and i think we
came out of it pretty well
one of the things is that uh vikings
culture uh has people love revisiting
viking culture what do you think it is
about uh the vikings that people love
watching on screen and
reading and watching
i think it's a simpler time like the
basics of the viking era as have been
butchered and bastardized by historians
over the last couple of hundred years is
uh i want this i go here uh i hit it
with my axe um and and you can have it
it's a simpler way of living and i think
in these complicated and quite scary
times that we live in now that's that's
quite seductive um i also think that is
why
when people meet godwin in this viking
universe people will be
uh they will underestimate what this
side character could be made of
uh one of the other things that's uh
interesting or cool about this show is
you don't have to have watched any of
the other vikings to just jump in on
this one but did you actually to get
ready for the roll did you binge all the
previous seasons like how did you
actually get ready to step on set that
first day
um i'd seen a fair amount of it over the
years beforehand um the producers of
this uh also made the borges that i had
made back in 20
2011 2010 um so i've known i've known
morgan and a whole load of the guys here
for a very long time um i mean that was
actually one of the really nice things
about screen tests i rocked up in dublin
um
back in 2019
and i met a whole load of friends i knew
the casting director very well i knew
the exact producers very well but the
only person who really didn't know at
that point was jeb and
we've gone famously he's a he's a good
friend now on that note i gotta stop i'm
just gonna say again congrats on being
part of the series i know it's gonna be
a huge hit and i look forward to talking
to you for season three and beyond
uh i can't wait
thank you stephen